let's talk about this movie fistfight
this is I really like the idea behind
this movement you can talk about the the
plot the idea of it first just so people
understand what what the movies about
well it's uh it takes place in a in a
high school in the last day of school
and it's a pretty crazy high school you
know it's kind of like you know Animal
House kind of you know they doing
everything for those that remember
having them our house but uh but it's
the last day of school and then you know
two teachers decide yo
three o'clock after school we're gonna
get it on right right yay so it's
hashtag teacher fight yeah you know I'm
sayin so I'm one of the teachers you're
the one that kind of wants to fight yeah
you know Charlie days the other other
teacher yeah Charlie days the he's the
wimpy teacher yeah you know he's the one
who really don't want to fight
yeah well we got a clip here let's take
a look at a clip that explains a little
bit about fistfight
[Music]
I'm gonna fight you I'm sorry what
parking lot after school its own did you
don't fight I want everybody to see this
[Applause]
Tagg teacher fight couse knows about
this I don't need to be liked
I need to educate
I don't know the first thing about
fighting mega truce
[Music]
are you serious 1300 about no running
would you see this game there's nothing
that punch and then just go down play
dead like possums do or anything that's
like a like a [ __ ] animal there's a
crazy guy at my high school he's trying
to beat me up if you have a problem with
a bully I need you to speak to a teacher
I am a teacher
[Applause]
right here
you know it's choice cuz you see Charlie
day is part of a funny guy you got to
work with them did you get a sense of
how you might do if you really had to
fight Charlie Day in real life if it was
ice cube I'm serious it was ice cube
versus Charlie day in real life what
would happen Oh Lord
I mean Charlie day look like you look
sneaky yeah look like look like that
sneaky you know I mean like you get you
so I'm not sure you know he you might
have you know he looked like he can bite
real good you know a good ball grab or
he stick you with a safety pin he keeps
a safety pin on him just on me yeah
dirty yeah gotta fight dirty yeah yeah
yeah so you think he might win but he'd
do it in the dirt no no he won't win but
he will fight me dirty ok I'm prepared
for it all all right
you